windows laptop manufacturers have been
on a roll lately
and razer just took it to a whole other
level with their first productivity
laptop
the razer book 13. it's almost like
razer watched our cell
13 review and fixed every single
complaint that we had
making this my new favorite windows
laptop
and yes i do think it's worth the extra
price over the xps 13
for two reasons that i'll cover in just
a bit in this review i'll tell you
everything they fixed and improved along
with one
absolutely horrific change they made
which makes no sense at all
and it could be a deal breaker for some
people along with that
i have to make a few comparisons to the
new m1 macbooks
since those have made a huge bang in the
market
and even dedicated windows fans are
being tempted to change
but i'll save that for the end starting
off the build quality used to be great
with older razer laptops
but this time it is amazing with no
chassis flex
and some parts that used to be plastic
are now actually all aluminum
coming in at a total weight of three
pounds i only have two minor complaints
here
one is that the display is tough to open
with one hand
a deeper groove would have made this
much easier and the other
is that there's random glue residue on
both sides by the ports
even though it was brand new which is
really off-putting on a 1600
laptop the razer book is only sold in
their great looking mercury color
and because of that fingerprints are no
longer an issue at least on the chassis
itself
on the left side we have three ports a
usb type-c
thunderbolt 4 port a standard usb port
and a headphone mic combo jack which i
really like being on the left side since
it doesn't get in the way when i'm using
a mouse
thankfully we have another thunderbolt 4
port on the right side which was one of
my complaints in the past
so i'm really glad that razer finally
added another one so you still have a
powerful port
if you connect it to a egpu we also have
an hdmi 2.0 port for connecting to
displays without having any limitations
and a microsd card reader now personally
i would much rather have a full size sd
card reader
but microsd is more flexible since you
could use an adapter
in regular cameras and of course it is
much better than what apple offers
powering this machine is a new slim 65
watt usb type-c
power brick which is so nice after the
huge chunky ones in the past
and that also means that you can power
it from either side taking a look inside
the keyboard
looks and feels great we have razer's
usual customizable rgb lighting which i
don't really care for personally
but on the bright side the back lighting
is very bright
which you kind of need for white keys
which also
show much more dirt than black keys as
for the keyboard feel it is
very good so much better than what razer
used to offer a few years ago
now personally i would rate it just as
good as apple's new magic keyboards
which puts it slightly behind the new
dell xps 13s
the keyboard the non-two-in-one model
which is my favorite
with that said razer has a winner on
their hands and most people will be
thrilled
typing on this laptop and below that we
have a massive
apple like trackpad just over a year ago
razer had
the most frustrating trackpad that i
have ever used in a premium laptop
and now it is one of the best in terms
of windows laptops
matching up to the new xps 13 which is
fantastic
great job razer for this massive upgrade
on the sides we have speaker grilles
which no longer use a cloth cover so
they both
look and feel more premium and then at
the bottom of the laptop we have this
thx sticker
signifying that the speaker should be
fairly high quality
unfortunately that is not the case at
least out of the box
go ahead and take a listen to yourselves
compared to the cheaper
macbook pro
[Music]
yeah it is that bad i don't know how
this kind of sound is coming from a
premium
laptop i know that razer speakers were
never really good in the past
but the razer blade stealth not only
sounded better
but it was much louder as well we have
no bass
the mids are very thin and the high
frequencies are
way too sharp and then the volume cuts
down as soon as there is
any bass in the audio leading to
probably the worst laptop audio i have
heard in many years
and that just makes no sense because
razer made
dedicated speaker enclosures that sit on
rubber mounts
which many companies don't do so why is
the sound so bad i looked into the
settings and found a special menu for
the thx spatial audio
and i was able to disable that which
fixed the crunchy highs
and the volume modulation but then at
the same time it made the speakers
way too quiet for normal use which is a
bummer
now you can crank up the eq all the way
which does increase the volume but then
the sound quality goes down
by a fair bit i don't know how they
could have messed this up so bad
when just six months ago i praised them
for the speaker upgrade
now if you use headphones it won't be a
big deal but for me this is my only
major complaint
so let's hope that they could fix this
in software on the plus side
razer absolutely killed the webcam and
microphone
it was pretty good last year but razer
took a clue from our current situation
and they doubled the microphones to a
total of four
all of which are front facing and the
720p webcams processing is also fairly
good
here's how it compares to the new xps
13. this is the microphone and webcam
quality of the razer book in a fairly
well-lit room
and this is the webcam and microphone
quality from the 2020
dell xps 13. and to make it even better
it also supports windows hello which we
love
so it logs you in as soon as you open it
there's no need to enter a password or
touch a fingerprint sensor and now let's
get into the display where razer
once again made major strides
ours has the 1200p touchscreen panel so
you do lose out on some sharpness
compared to the 4k model but with that
you also gain about three to four hours
of battery life which is a worthy
trade-off
if you work on the go i've always
complained about the massive bezels and
chins on razer laptops
and that the by 9 aspect ratio wasn't
great for productivity
and now we have a beautiful 16 by 10
display
which not only gives us more real estate
but it also gets rid of that ugly chin
and because of that we also have super
slim bezels on the sides
apple please take notes for the 14 inch
macbook pro
now these changes alone would be enough
for us to praise razer
but they didn't stop there brightness
went from an average
350 nits to a class leading 500 nits
and with that reflectivity was also
really cut down
so this machine is perfect for use in
bright rooms and outdoors
and if that wasn't enough the viewing
angles are also
super wide at 178 degrees smoking
apple's displays
my only complaint as far as the display
is that we don't have the dci p3 wide
colors
that apple and dell are offering so if
you're a high-end
photo or video editor wanting more than
srgb
on the internal display keep that in
mind and now let's finally get into
performance
and the razer book delivers with the
best on-the-go performance you can get
in an ultrabook
aside from going with one of the new m1
max our model has 16 gigs of ram which
is an upgradable and a 256 gigabyte ssd
which is about half of what the
competitors offer for this same price
now thankfully it is super fast storage
beating out the new max
even at half the capacity and with that
it is very easily upgradable so for
about 200 bucks you can pop in our
recommended two terabyte ssd
which is even faster i'll go ahead and
link that down in the description below
taking a look at cpu performance the top
top-end 11-gen i7 intel processor
performs about the same in geekbench 5
as the competitors like dell that are
also using the same chip
now of course we would expect that but
what we didn't expect
is how the razer book performs when we
unplug it
the performance did not go down like
most windows laptops
it actually went up a little bit and yes
we did make sure
all of the throttling options were
turned off on that dell
this means that when you're on battery
power the razer
smokes the dell and not only that the
new vapor chamber cooling
runs cooler and quieter than the xps as
well
because of that under 100 cpu load in
cinebench the razer book is able to run
faster and score significantly higher
than the xps 13.
when we unplug it the performance does
drop this time
but even unplugged the razer performs
close to the dell
with that being plugged in graphics wise
the razer book performs really well
scoring about a thousand points higher
than the same exact gpu in the dell when
looking at geekbench
and it also gets at 9 frames per second
more in gfx bench's gaming test
thanks to the better cooling now of
course the more expensive
high-end razer blade 13 with a dedicated
1650 ti has more graphics power
which can definitely help as long as you
keep it plugged in to get the full
performance
and along with that the new macbook pro
with the m1 chip
also beats out the razer book not only
in terms of graphics as you guys can see
here
but also in cpu performance as well with
that it also runs quieter thanks to the
cpu
only needing 13 watts of power compared
to over
25 watts and because of that the mac
will get about double the battery life
as well doing the same tasks so is it
worth buying the razer book
if you're somebody that doesn't need
windows no
not really and even though the razer
book is the best windows ultrabook
the mac still beats it as far as display
trackpad
performance and it is actually cheaper
as long as you don't want a massive ssd
but of course many people need or prefer
windows
and having the ability to hook up
multiple external displays
and also hooking up a egp which can
really boost your graphics performance
when you're at your desk those are all
things that the m1 macbooks can't do
so if you're in the market for a windows
ultrabook the razer book is an
excellent machine and in my opinion it
is the best windows ultrabook
and as long as you don't need good
speakers built into the laptop itself
i would highly recommend it now if you
don't need windows go ahead and check
out my ultra detailed comparison to the
m1 macbook pro
or my video editing comparison right
over there and if you enjoy this video
click that circle above to subscribe
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]